Fox News hosts and guests flipping their
Lids as the Red Wave collapsed crumbled
it was like you know when you put cotton
candy in water and it just disappears
that was the the Red Wave disappearing
last night
check out some of these clips starting
with
Fox News pundit Mark Thiessen saying
this is a disaster for the Republican
party just think about this uh we
welcome back martesan and hell for
juniors of the panel
um we talked a lot about debates and
when some candidates did debates and
some didn't do them had the October 25th
debate been September 30th would this
race have changed what I I think it
might have or maybe it wouldn't have I
mean I think there's a broader issue
here which is that so think about this
we have the worst inflation in four
decades the worst collapse in real wages
in 40 years the worst crime wave since
the 1990s the worst border crisis in U.S
history we have Joe Biden who is the
least popular president since Harry
Truman says now none of this stuff is
true and I'll prove it in a moment
presidential polling happened and there
wasn't a red wave that is a searing
indictment of the Republican Party All
right so a lot a lot a lot of admitting
there that this is a disaster Brian
Kilmeade with a similar perspective
repeating many of the same lies shifted
and right now zeldin's probably within
five points it might be out of reach for
him there's no big concession there you
see there's some unhappiness but I don't
know about you guys I'm shocked there
was a no Red Wave if you think about
inflation a 40-year high crime that was
since the 1980s the unpopular president
with an agenda that's more green
oriented than people oriented yeah
they are telling you all lies okay yes
they are correctly pointing out the Red
Wave failed credit to them for pointing
that out but let's fact check this I
love it worst inflation in four decades
they say
reality it's the worst inflation since
1989 it's 33 years it did hit pieces of
four decades maybe we give them a pass
on that one but check out some of these
other ones worst collapse in real wages
in 40 years that would take us to 1982.
that is very clearly not true
median inflation adjusted that's what
they mean by real inflation adjusted
wages
that is not a chart that suggests now
wages are at their lowest point in 40
years in fact it is very much the
opposite very very much the opposite
we're at a peak not at the bottom they
are liars they said worse crime since
the 1990s or the 1980s even that's also
not true here's the crime rate since the
1990s and as you can see it has actually
declined over that period of time it is
declined even if you look specifically
as we will do now at murder homicide
those rates have also declined although
they have very recently ticked up a hair
but overall it is part of a downward
Trend worst border crisis in history
they say well I don't know how you
measure that is it the number of people
you catch or that you don't catch it is
true that arrests at the order are up
but that means we're catching people
that means they're not getting in here
how is that a crisis and importantly
nothing really has changed under Biden
since Donald Trump at the border and
then lastly they they said Biden least
popular president since Truman
that's not true Joe Biden right now is
about as popular as Trump was at this
point in his presidency about as popular
as Ronald Reagan was at this point in
his presidency within a point or two of
Barack Obama and Clinton's popularity at
this point in their presidencies and by
the way were it not for 9 11 which Bowie
George W Bush's approval rating uh Biden
would be doing better than George W bush
as well that the reason Bush ended up
with temporarily a higher approval was 9
11. okay every claim is a lie they are
Furious maybe look at reality
historically low unemployment
um stock market GDP you know all the
indicators we talk about and then maybe
they would be a little bit less shocked
if you have a friend or loved one who is
passionate about the environment here is
a perfect holiday gift our sponsor
established titles is a project that
lets you ceremonially purchase as little
as one square foot of dedicated land in
edelston Scotland so that you can call
yourself a lord or a lady like the
historic Scottish tradition some people
even change their plane tickets or
credit cards to include Lord or lady
your title pack comes with an official
certificate you can see exactly where
your plot of land is located it makes a
perfect last minute gift but most
importantly established titles plants
one free tree for every plot of land
sold established titles does really good
work all over the world with
reforestation organizations like one
tree planted and trees for the future so
you'll have a great laugh whether you're
Scottish or not I'm not but you're
giving the gift gift of reforestation to
fight climate change if you use my link
you'll get 10 percent off and your plot
of land will be right next to mine you
can see it on a map go to established
titles.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman for an extra 10 off on top of
their Black Friday deal the link is down
below